um sonho quando fui convidado para essa
palestra eu não entendi o porquê ea
razão do convite depois de noites mal
dormidas eu descobrir que eu tinha uma
mensagem a passar para o mundo
eu sou um velhinho aposentado não um
velhinho como dessa figura um velhinho
tristonho decrépito morimbundo vocês da
platéia vocês jovens gostariam de estar
com a cara desse velhinho respondem não
vocês gostariam de estar com o sorriso
desses outros velhinhos
eu me encontro neste estado de
felicidade e durante a palestra
vocês vão perceber o porquê eu estou
nesse estado de felicidade
durante a minha vida eu preparei para
minha aposentadoria
desde menino comecei a aprender a jogar
xadrez e joga até hoje
depois aprendi a jogar tênis e contínuo
praticando até hoje aos 40 anos já um
pouquinho velho aprendi a jogar o pedir
pra fugir do alzheimer
aos 50 anos eu fiz o meu primeiro curso
de vinho e fiquei maluco por esse
sistema
estudei muito e muito estava eu por
aposentar
trabalhei numa siderúrgica durante 35
anos
essa empresa estava preocupada com alto
índice de alcoolismo e também com quadro
depressivo dos seus velhinhos por
aposentar e ela lançou o programa 55
mais 55 e lógico de idade e nesse
programa o objetivo era preparar os seus
funcionários para aposentadorias
ou seja desenvolver as suas habilidades
diferentes daquelas habilidades
necessário ao seu trabalho
isso que é preparar para uma
aposentadoria em uma das palestras o
palestrante falou
pense no seu sonho
escreva o seu sonho em um papel
eu escrevi o meu sonho na minha cabeça
meu sonho era grandioso
talvez impossível martin luther king
falou eu tenho um sonho
se ele tivesse falado eu tenho um
projeto
ninguém acreditaria nele e vocês vocês
têm o seu sonho
vamos fazer um exercício concentra e eu
vou dar 30 minutos
é para vocês escreverem o seu sonho na
cabeça
ok fecham seus olhos
a abordagem será que eu descobrirei
alguns sonhos de vocês será que alguém
pensou em fazer um curso de dança um
curso de pintura em que conste a com
gastronomia um curso básico de vinho ou
a loucura de pular de paraquedas
será que pensou vocês pensaram em fazer
um novo curso de sedução melhorar o
relacionamento com o seu namorado com
sua esposa e assim por diante
como organizar o seu sonho
colocando o seu sonho para funcionar
antes de dar o primeiro passo
separe o seu sonho na fantasia seja
realista
acredite no seu sonho
não deixe seu sonho escapar o primeiro
passo
crie um plano de ação segundo conti seu
sonho para os seus amigos eles poderão
te ajudar seja perseverante transforme
os nãos em cincy coloque em prática seu
sonho o meu case wine ordem adventure
comecei a planejar freneticamente o meu
sonho
aproveitei o drama de chicago diagrama
de che caua mais conhecido como diagrama
de espinha de peixe é uma ferramenta
muito interessante para qualquer projeto
que você tem na vida
veja que eu falei agora projeto eu tinha
um sonho
agora eu tenho um projeto coloquei na
cabeça do peixe as regiões vinícolas na
espinha lateral ou coloquei os países e
na nave de espinho no sentido
longitudinal do peixe
regiões de livros e assim por diante
você pode dizer destrinchar em várias
espinhos do lado direito por exemplo
coloquei vinícolas da frança e nas
caixinhas as regiões vinícolas e nas
outras algumas vinícolas isso vai reunir
com meus filhos dois filhos e falei do
meu só uma emoção muito bem
expliquei pra eles meu filho não estou
meus filhos estou a apresentar e vou
fazer uma volta o mundo
eu também quero ir esse meu filho eu
também vou diz minha filha a alma a alma
ainda não coloquei não fiz um orçamento
financeiro partir depois de todo o
planejamento fazer foi o o orçamento
chegou à casa de 800 mil reais reunir
meus filhos novamente fazia um sonho
acabou
eu não tenho essa grande acabou meu
filho formado em publicidade e photoshop
profissional falou o pai vamos buscar um
patrocinador
eu respondi pra eles meu filho e vai
querer patrocinar um maluco como é o que
querem na estradas bebendo pelas
estradas
quem vai querer fazer um negócio desse
bem fizemos um book com buck na mão sair
mais tarde patrocinadores
qual é o foco de veículos é lógico
mandei um e mail para as vinícolas do
mundo inteiro
fui em bento gonçalves reuniu todos os
meninos mostrei meu projeto tranquilo
vou dar dinheiro para esse projeto não
os nãos e não os dois sonhos era tão
pequeno que não dava nem pra chegar na
argentina muito bem nessas despesas
maiores eram com aluguel de carro
hospedagem e alimentação
peraí por que não comprar um motor-home
mil não tenha essa grana aí porque não
ganharam um motor-home muito bem
contei os meus sonhos para alguns amigos
e um deles me falou eu tenho uma idéia
pega esse telefone é do presidente de
uma fábrica de caminhão de chassi
numa manhã de um sábado
resolvi na cara de pau link direto com o
presidente e falei em dez minutos e
expliquei meu sonho ele virou assim é só
escolher o chassi
eu caí duro não sabia nem mais o que
falar
desliguei o telefone muito obrigado ele
falou que a secretária dele entra em
contato muito bem
passaram se três meses de expectativa e
nada até que um dia a secretária
telefonou pra mim e eu fiquei naquela
dúvida será que eles captaram querendo
me vender um chassi ou será que ele
entendeu que eu quero ganhar fácil
fiquei com essa dúvida aí é convocar uma
reunião um gerente de marketing que vai
poupar se fosse o gerente comercial
estava preocupado acho que ele entendeu
o meu recado
chega lá apresentei o projeto foi
detalhado maravilha slides e tudo e faz
olha o seu projecto vai de encontro ao
nosso marketing
nós queremos mostrar o brasil que o
chassi de nossa empresa é bastante
adaptável uma casa rodante
não estou entendendo uma questão você
pediu três já se você vai fazer uma
caravana um motor-home pra você e um
para cada filho risos muito bem senão
ninguém vai colocar dinheiro no negócio
mas como criatividade de negociação
ninguém vai colocar não existe isso
existe
já conversei com o fabricante da casa e
ele topa receber dois chassi para
construir a casa
então você não vai pagar imposto vai
entrar como custo
então tá provado
o gesto não tá ele fosse está aprovado o
projeto vai cair tudo
dia 11 de outubro o chassi chegou em
pirassununga para fabricar o motor-home
isso nós já tínhamos do projeto começou
a protásio adesivagem escolher o nome
que escolheu o nome de wine word advento
e os três filhos começará já os 33
pessoas começaram a ser chamado
aventureiros do vinho
meu filho foto ao profissional 27 anos
minha filha responsável pela filmagem e
pela parte de enoturismo e toda
logística eu degustador de vinho
profissional 1º de janeiro de 2012
eu tinha aposentado em setembro de 2011
não deu nem tempo para o ócio 1º de
janeiro 2012 partimos
eu nunca tinha dirigido um caminhão na
minha vida o meu filho tinha falado
sobre a mídia espontânea que a mídia
espontânea geraria uma oportunidade para
conseguir um patrocinador nem começamos
já estava a mídia espontânea atrás da
gente
cobertura de televisão do sbt com três
bicicletas nas costas partimos rumo à
região vinícola do santa catarina
como todo o planejamento tem os seus
furos tive que parar em varginha
por que a mídia espontânea e meus amigos
estavam lá tive que dar uma paradinha e
também fora da programação tive que
parar em santa rita do sapucaí porque um
maluco também acreditou nesse maluco
aqui me forneceu o nome de um sistema de
telefonia móvel
não posso falar o nome da empresa mas
vocês vão deduzir muito facilmente
notada porque nem fazer merchandising e
me conheceu esse equipamento que nos
ajudou muito muito bem
começamos a nossa viagem
onde estamos as regiões vinícolas de
santa catarina
depois vale dos vinhedos penetramos luxo
ir para o uruguai
vamos lá em foz do iguaçu para uma
aventura já estava mídia espontânea
atrás de mim santa catarina fizeram um
bom dia santa catarina e continuamos nos
jornais começaram a pipocar a história
desse maluco
ok primeira vinícola villa francioni
vinho nacional
pra mim foi uma emoção muito grande era
o começo do meu sonho dentro conçalves
salton dele com uma única degustação em
barris
fui uruguai região vinícola de canelones
bodega bouza estagnar e nicol frescobol
participando do salão de vinho
internacional relatava origina atrás de
mim olha danada despontando atrás de mim
eu nem amigos nem sabia que era muito
espontânea argentina fomos até a terra
do fogo
ninguém olhando o meu filho o show high
a terra do fogo na neve
o tino e o filho foi preso em um raio
depois nós conseguimos soltá lo o
telefone móvel aqui ajudou muito
aí fomos continuamos perito moreno o
galo sempre foi o campeão do gelo
tivemos que não precisa nem falar que eu
sou atleticano de niro engenheiros da
patagônia bodega final do mundo vale
perdido e várias vinícolas mendonça
pinheiro de mendonça degustação técnica
e profissional
nico gama lei conformea catena ícone da
argentina
subimos para o chile para fazer passando
por todas as regiões vinícolas biobío ea
tamaulipa o chá com água e assim por
diante
parque nacional de torres del paine um
lugar fantástico paisagens maravilhosas
a você descobrir quem era o dono do
racismo é e veco ok continuando lance
aubrey passando para o lado chileno por
com brincando paisagem vinícola uma sala
de barris degustação profissional
novamente jogo filmando um jogo de pólo
vinícola casa silva
embarcamos um motor home em valparaíso
para os estados unidos
atravessamos todo o deserto chegamos são
de ambos em diego e fomos visitar as
vinícolas do mapa vale ouro e com othon
francisco travessão do gol de bicicleta
na valley
eu tô com gordinha mas é o vento é o
vento também entramos no no canadá havia
vancouver o canadá a vale atravessamos
todo o canadá até agora falsa também tem
alguns vinhos wine um vinho do gelo
o resto é tudo porcaria do gelo contreau
toronto
o edson pio adoro tênis e lembro provei
tamo tudo organizado para chegar
exatamente o dia da ufpe
embarcamos um motor-home nova york para
a alemanha
atravessamos todo o mozy um lugar
fantástico vinhos maravilhosos foto
bonita
meu filho coreano uva chegamos no
benchmark do mundo do vinho a frança que
foi sempre o meu sonho e visitando as
regiões de porto por goiânia champanhe
atravessamos aí a região de champanhe e
eu tinha previsto ganhei de uma empresa
concorrente para a neve
cheguei lá nanoporo eu não sabia colocar
corrente deve esperar neve passar para
continuar vinhedo coberto de neve bortot
morre a região vinícola do mundo
chato opção nem deveres
olha você vê os castelos onde gostei os
melhores vinhos do mundo
jeff goldblum a modalidade olha que
templo degustação em barril de novo os
maiores vinhos do mundo chapola puxa a
tomar gol chutou petrus montanha rotich
de chatô pav chatô cheval blanc
esse era o meu sonho já tou de quem os
melhores 20 sobremesa do mundo uma
passadinha em montblanc porque estava
cansado estressado deveria muito vinho
tinha que descansar um pouco
degustando vinhos velhos um passeio em
londres torneio de wimbledon tudo
sincronizado tudo organizado
depois de espanha e portugal fizemos
todo o trajeto região de de ribeiro deu
de ouro r orra vinícolas fantásticas com
arquitetura maravilhosa lugares mágicos
lindos reis sala de degustação técnica
estava de novo a mídia espontânea em
honra atrás da gente é bom dia não é
queridos amigos negócio 10 e estava na
nossa três lá a em pamplona uma
brincadeira touro santiago de compostela
o douro em portugal
quinta do noval lugar fantástico
percorremos toda a borda da itália
passando o piemonte toscana verona e
assim por diante lago de garda lago de
como trentino veneza piemonte que a
principal região vinícola italiana e
talvez do mundo
tomamos grandes vinhos como barollo
toscana tomamos os vinhos que antes
espetaculares iene continuar entre os
grandes vinhos italianos que agnelo
solae a meu filho e fazer uma
demonstração técnica ainda no vinho na
feira também castelo de buffy florença
torre de pisa menininha tentando segurar
a torre que está por aí
capri se impor diante reviera napolitana
vinhedos da genebra suíça áustria
depois fomos para o lado ocidental praga
eslovênia é um dos lugares mais bonitos
que eu conheci o da peste vuitton e
oremos tocar nos 20 sobremesa do mundo
croácia atenas santorini grécia e
istambul
estávamos em istambul ea gente fica
alienado do mundo que coisa gostosa não
via notícias do brasil no vina notícias
de morte de políticos e t7 certa
totalmente alienada estampou resolvemos
ir no egito estava fora do script fora
do planejamento
compramos uma passagem por 50 euros
baratinho à meia noite
deixei o motor home no aeroporto
chegamos às 5 horas da manhã a directora
do hotel
acordei no no avião só tinha 13 passou
três aventureiros há vazio avião no
hotel café da manhã cinco pessoas dois
malucos de nós três
saímos na rua tanque para todo com
telado fechou o museu e as pirâmides
devemos contratar uma empresa junto com
o hotel com segurança dizendo dois dias
de ficam três dias confinados no hotel e
se tudo planejamento as pirâmides a
noite lá tem cinco mil cadeiras
futurista tinha quatro malucos como guia
e nós três
depois stellenbosch quando as regiões
vinícolas mais bonita da áfrica do sul a
áfrica do sul faz vinhos gente vê os
fantásticos lugar bonito lugar mágico
jantares não recebido com jantares com
vinho uma coisa estressante horrível é
que a cop atleticano também fomos ver o
galo ser campeão uma nova decepção mas
foi bom encontrar mais de 30 mil amigos
de belo horizonte
nós estávamos sentindo falta da
sociabilidade do brasileiro
isso que nós temos não existe no mundo
por isso que eu estou voltando a morar
no brasil
aí
e só pra foto ninguém do caminho nada
depois austrália percorremos sydney e
visitamos as regiões vinícolas de
barbosa vale ea valley e assim por
diante tomando os grandes se raça na
austrália
umas fotos austrália jardim zoológico
nada de natureza
isso aí o penfold's grange um dos
maiores dos vinhos do mundo roberto
parque de 98 pontos desse vinho praias
magníficas vinheta espetaculares
melburne estava novamente programado
aberto da austrália
tudo sincronizado organização perfeita
da viagem e djokovic e chegamos no
último país nova zelândia
percorremos com a 7 mil quilômetros na
nova zelândia degustando vinhos paisagem
fantástica um país maravilhoso com as
fotos da nova zelândia central otago
olha onde tem vinhedo aquilo que
paisagem fantástica bonito né
aí o sonho dos meus filhos
as loucuras dele por lá de banco nem sei
como falar em playboy dela aqui o dia a
dia consertando o motor rondon um
trabalho danado tenta canseira
cozinhando jogando golfe uma tristeza
difícil jogando tênis na avenida que tem
tem quadra de tênis e um barril e
fermentação ao lado o dólar estar num
não existe né
números da maratona duração de dois anos
e três meses eram previstos três anos
diminuir um pouquinho pra chegar na copa
do mundo o brasil ver o brasil perder da
alemanha países visitados eram 24 tudo
planejado fizemos 34 270 cidades quase
90 mil quilômetros visitando os 42
regiões vinícolas
eram cerca de 90 diminuiu 42 não está
muito cansado depois 162 regiões
vinícolas visitadas 2.951 vinhos de gol
estados comentados e fotografados total
gasto 450 mil reais
é muito dinheiro é mas é viável
eu aluguei minha casa peguei meu salário
aposentadoria não pagava mais iptu luz
telefone tatau e foi viável
então gente é muito fácil você realizar
seus sonhos
tem que planejar muito bem perdeu furado
dois problemas mecânicos perfuração do
radiador muito pouco problema com o
carro mas estava tudo pago pela iveco
fiz a fazia prevenção mim preventiva em
várias cidades não precisava trocar nada
fácil em troca tudo não deu defeito
nenhum par carro espetacular também né
meu novo sonho eu continuo sonhando
aliás já está em pra esse motor home
virou escola e itinerante de vinhos
aqui em santa rita tem uma turma de bebê
do jardim karina já dei cinco cursos que
vem estou formando uma uns degustadores
aqui daqui a pouco vai emanar a álcool
ea prefeitura talvez vai atrás de mim
vamos lá viró acrescentei só aquela
quadradinho e continuou merchandising
meu site wine ordenamento ponto com
vocês podem lá ficar lendo eu acho que
vão ficar pelo menos um ano lento e
muita história lá lá dentro
meu e mail pra quem quiser o próximo
curso de vinhos em novembro
horácio arroba online world evento
pontocom
siga o seu coração e viva os seus sonhos
muito obrigado